before we get on to that interview and
coronavirus will generally I just want
to get your reaction to the stabbings
that we've seen in Redding where three
people have sadly lost their lives well
it was terrible scenes that we saw in
reading last night and my thoughts and
prayers are with the families and the
friends of those affected we don't yet
know the motives behind the stabbings I
trust the police to establish the facts
and bring the perpetrator to justice but
it's terrible scenes that we witnessed
okay and now as you say a fast unfolding
story we're gonna be hearing a lot more
about it on Sky News later today and we
just heard from the House Secretariat
and that Hancock who was talking about I
guess the need for people to go out to
shop to start reopening the economy
because he believes that the government
is managing to now suppress the virus do
you think it's safe to go shopping well
I went to shop yesterday to buy Father's
Day presents for my husband on behalf of
my children so I did that I wore a face
mask I tried to as best as I could to be
socially distance from other people in
the in the shop we all want the economy
to get back up and running and actually
perhaps on a more basic level we all
want to be able to spend more time with
friends and families and loved ones in a
way that we haven't been able to do for
the last and almost three months now so
we all want to get back to some degree
of normality but we need to do it in a
safe way and we'll wait to see what the
the scientists say this coming week
about relaxing the restrictions from 2
meters to 1 meter we all want to get
there as soon as possible but it is
incredibly important we follow the
science and do this in a safe way I want
to talk to you about schools is it safe
for parents to send their children back
to school well schools have stayed open
safely throughout this pandemic and
throughout the lockdown more children
started going back to school in June and
that was done safely I would like to see
more children returned to school safely
but the truth is the government's have
failed in the commitments that they made
to parents and
the country which was to return all
primary school children to school safely
before the summer holidays and frankly I
don't know what the education secretary
Gavin Williamson has been doing for the
last three months because he should have
been using this period of lockdown to
prepare schools to ensure that the space
is available because many schools are
crammed particularly in inner-city areas
were going to struggle with the smaller
bubbles in which children need to be
taught in and so the government should
have been working with libraries with
community centers with leisure centers
to open them potentially as school
settings or putting temporary buildings
in the government didn't do that they
were asleep of the wheel Gavin
Williamson was set a test he has failed
it miserably and now the government are
trying to blame other people but their
failure to get schools open I think that
schools could have opened safely but all
children before the summer holidays if
the government would have thrown
everything into it so you're saying
there about how you would like to see
more children go back to schools safely
but I can't help but thinking what does
safely actually mean it's a political
decision isn't it's not always a
scientific decision the scientists are
never going to say green light red light
things are safe or not safe it's a
balance of risk isn't it you know we
criticize the government hiding behind
the science but sometimes I wonder if
lay behinds behind the science bit too
is it safe for more children to go back
to school now well more children are
going back to school every week more
children are returning to school safely
because schools are putting in place the
measures to make it safe but the
government could have done much more to
get more children to school safely and
labor put forward constructive proposals
like using libraries and leisure centers
it was possible to do this if government
had have thrown more into it it's not
possible in all school settings at the
moment to bring all children back
because there aren't enough bathrooms to
teach those smaller groups of people and
that's why the government should have
been using this period of lockdown to
enable more children to return to school
safely the government now say that
should they cut the social distancing
regulations from 2 meters to 1 meter
then well if the scientists had advised
that this week then of course that would
make a difference but I believe even
with the social distancing mesh
that we've got in place now at two
meters more children could have been
brought back into a school setting if
the government had have made the effort
to use other buildings to bring in
temporary staff to put up temporary
buildings those are the sorts of
measures that should have been taken
over the last few months because you
know by September children would have
missed out on six months of Education
the schools have done their best to
ensure home schooling but we know that
many children haven't accessed that it
is imperative that the government but
the needs of children in the education
of children first they're now being
complacent about getting all children
back by September but again I would urge
the government to do the work now to
make that possible and also to ensure
that those children who have fallen
behind are given more support to be able
to catch up so we don't have a
generation who are left behind and
locked out of future opportunities
because of mistakes made during this
pandemic now you have a very economic
background so I'm interested to know
about your thoughts on the current
economic picture in the United Kingdom
with figures out this week showing that
UK debt is greater the GDP greater than
the entire economy as we try and work
out how to ease our way out of lockdown
how worried should we be by the economic
picture well the economic picture is
incredibly worrying and you put the
point Sophie - Matthew Hancock that we
both have the highest number of deaths
in Europe and at the same time we're now
forecast by the organisation of Economic
Cooperation and Development the
international economic think tank that
we're going to have the deepest
recession of any country in the
developed world and that is incredibly
worrying and the two are related because
we came too late we were too slow on
lock down we were too slow to get
personal protective equipment and
clothing to those on the front line too
slow to put a protective ring around our
care homes and as a result the virus was
left unchecked in many places to go
through our communities and as a result
it is harder here to ease the lockdown
and also because as again as you put so
Matthew Hancock we've failed to put in
place the tests to trace and
isolate and system that we need and all
of these are having their toll not just
on lives but also on livelihoods and
their figures both on the the debt and
the deficit but also the jobs figures
and the and the fall in GDP in March
should give us all huge cause concern
and we do need from the Chancellor a
budget for jobs back to work budget in
July this year to quickly get on top of
this to support people to go back to
work to protect jobs and to support
those sectors of the economy that are
most impacted by this crisis there are
practical measures that the government
put in place for example to support
sectors like Hospitality's to support
coastal communities that are politically
affected by the lack of tourism that
we've seen in the last few weeks and
months and we'll be talking about more
about air the hospitality industry we're
there the chef or telling you a little
bit later on and I'm keen just to talk
to you a little bit about labor and
their labor party because there was a
review out this week into why labor lost
the election and it concluded that it
was a combination of having a non
popular leader and manifesto that many
people regarded as a fantasy and a
confused message on brexit so if that's
the case why did you elect a man to lead
a labor party who was responsible for
Labor's position on brexit at the last
election he had a brexit secretary well
I've been a member of the Labor Party
now for nearly 25 years and I've
campaigned in every election lately and
Ashley since I joined the party no one
underestimates the scale of the
challenge anybody who knocked on doors
both in the election in December last
year but also the last few general
elections knows what a mountain labor
has to climb but I think also everybody
can see that in the last two and a bit
months theist Alma has been leader of
the Labor Party that we've begun to
climb that mountain people can see in
Kirsten were a different sort of
opposition a constructive opposition
holding the government to account but
also they see in Kherson I just want to
go back to the specific question I asked
which was on brexit because Ana Paula of
Labor members carried out for the
report 57% named the brexit policy of
promising a second referendum on any
departure deal as the single most
unpopular and challenging idea to sell
to voters saying views were that it was
dithering dire and reflecting division
now you've decided that the man
responsible for that policy should lead
the party really learning the right
lessons from the election although all
of the party in the previous leadership
of the party were responsible for those
decisions I don't think that is the only
reason or even the biggest reason for
our defeat in the election in December
but let's look at where we are now in
the two months that Osama has been
leader of the Labour Party the poll
ratings have gone up more people
expressed confidence that Kia stahma
could be Prime Minister and lead our
country
nobody least of all yes Tama
underestimates the scale of the
challenge ahead of us but I think in the
last two months we've shown that is a
mountain that Labour can climb under
Kirsten's leadership and I'm proud to
serve in the Shadow Cabinet are under
here